hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zur zweiten folge christmas
kraft meine stimme hört sich gerade
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ich sag mal
kaffee an
auf gut deutsch einfach mal beschissen
ganz einfach weil ich bin gerade
aufgestanden bin kurz nach oben gegangen
hab ein bisschen damit man stimme
überhaupt noch ein bisschen annehmbar
klingt aber ich merke schon wenn ich
jetzt hier einfach so spreche dass es
echt einfach nur total komisches managte
mir jetzt fall dass es irgendwie so
keine ahnung die stimmbänder sind
morgens wenn man aufsteht immer noch ein
bisschen sah ich sag mal nicht so
aufgewärmt wenn man dann irgendwie du
schneller wenn man tee trinkt oder wenn
man allgemein viel redet dann werden
sich die stimmbänder auf dann kann man
besser reden die täter aber das hält
sich das thema tibet christmas crafter
oben ist ein fetter berg sehe ich gerade
aber naja ich würde einfach mal sagte
also ich würde einfach mal sagen ich
wollte immer eure kommentare einblenden
das habe ich jetzt mal vergessen zu
sagen und zwar blende ich jetzt mal
themen kommentare und pings einbau
kommentare was ich zu bauen soll wartet
das können wir einen ganz kurzen zu
bauen und zwar ist heute das thema von
ihr sehe eingeblendet mein thema
christkind glaubst du dran oder den
nikolaus also glaube ich an das
christkind über den nikolaus oder
irgendwie sowas und dabei ich mach mal
kurz ins loch hierzu also das ist nicht
das was wir bauen wollen wenn das der
fall luca chaos komische loch und das
was wir heute bauen werden ist du kannst
dein santa clause king bauen okay das
thema kommt nämlich von matthias 0 66 41
und der themen also der bau vorschlag
von bushido 12 34 100
gut ich verstehe zwar dass diese ganzen
komischen zeichen dahinter sollen
wie kann es auch einfach zu aufzubauen
oder sich verstehen dass die ganzen
zeichen dass einnahmen sollen aber
killerzellen sein jedem sich selbst
überlassen wie er sich nennt bei youtube
und naja jedenfalls besser als wenn man
seinen nachnamen nutzen naja jedenfalls
würde ich sagen dass jetzt eigentlich
schon direkt anfang an mit dem thema
darüber zu fassen
ich wollte ganz kurz etwas aussprechen
und zwar ein riesiges
danke schön an euch alle weil ihr so
aktiv teil gelesen seit bei der ersten
christmas graf folge die hat glaube ich
mittlerweile 1800 positive bewertungen
paar negative und ich glaube 1300
kommentare das ist echt eine menge weil
ich das einmal erwähnt habt dass ihr
dann so geschenke gewinnen können und
dass sie mir bitte themen die kommentare
schreibt da kamen echt eine menge sachen
analysis denke wenn ich die kommentare
einfach alle mal durch gruppe die da so
stehen habe ich schon themen für das
komplette projekt denke ich oder sachen
und da sind auch so witzige geschichten
dabei leicht kann ich ein paar songs im
kopf sagen ich werde davon jetzt die
ganzen stories welche ich nachher nehme
um das die gewinnen werde ich nachher
als nachher auslosen kurzform von vom 10
jetzt also nur noch acht tage jetzt wenn
ihr das video seht und was ich dann eben
beispiel moment kenne nicht mal wieder
aussieht ok ok jedenfalls zwei sachen
bei wie zum beispiel ja da wollte einer
geschenke suchen und ist dann in die
beiden leicht kette da gestolpert oder
so und das ach so übrigens ist das
cash-back geändert ich auch sagen zu
meine kraft war ich hab bei facebook
gefragt welches täglich verwenden soll
meine kraft oder das scharf und meinte
ich solle meine kraft verwende dachten
okay okay wenn ich meine kraft wenn ihr
wollt ok ok naja jedenfalls mein motto
war ich jedenfalls ist dieser diese
personen die die geschenke suchen wollte
was man eigentlich auch nicht machen
sollte ist dann über diese kette dort
gestolpert und daraufhin hat er mit
dieser kette einen pc runtergerissen
denen eigentlich bekommen hätte und ich
sags mal so der pcs dann quasi
runtergefallen aber auch noch im desktop
drin das alles kaputt gegangen dann hat
er doch kein pc bekommen weil ich also
wird sich die story ich glaube er fand
das damals nicht so witzig guck mal ganz
kurz was ich eigentlich für schuhe habe
nicht irgendwie ich möchte auch meine
schuhe als nichtig sie warte so geht's 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ok 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 fertig es
müssen jetzt ohnehin dass da unten auch
das sind die die die schon die
schnürsenkel die schuhe komische
geräusche dauer light gray wohl und die
mir nämlich warum wir noch das natürlich
blöd oder ich muss ich nehme mal kann
ich dir nicht irgendwie salat ich guck
mal kurz ob ich den ball links nicht ich
finde das kind ex noch eben wir dann
kann ich den nebenbei jetzt irgendwie
offen haben man kann ja auch mal ganz
gut über das thema quatschen was wir von
bushido vorgeschlagen wurde und zwar
glaube ich an das christkind
ach so jedenfalls die geschichte gegner
so zu ändern dass diese bestimmte person
dann den pc nicht bekommen hat einfach
weil er halt danach gesucht und ich
hätte eigentlich auch genauso reagiert
als elternteil als einfach unfair ist
sage ich mal nach geschenken suchen das
ist finde ich auch irgendwie doof was
ist dass man's can stop dass minsk in
schon mal ganz kurz
moment moment schon die webseiten
verbreitet das ist doch nicht das möchte
das ebenso so cool jetzt kann ich den
nachbarn ohne hier die ganze zeit so
komisch oder weiter moment in kürze also
christkind ja was will man da quatschen
also glaube ich ans christkind an alle
zuschauer die glaube ich also ich hab
mit ungefähr das weiß eigentlich jeder
dass das christkind nicht gibt das
wissen jetzt mittlerweile sogar schon
grundschulkinder bei uns was damals
wirklich so dass wir das geglaubt haben
oder vielleicht gibt's ja sogar noch
welche das glauben können wir in die
kommentare schreiben
ob wir noch ans christkind glaubt oder
eher nicht für mich definitiv
interessieren
und die also bei mir was eigentlich so
dass ich ich hab ja ok wir waren damals
in der kirche wollen wir also an
weihnachten und nachher lagen dann
irgendwie die geschenke seitdem habe ich
mich gefragt hat seitdem ich so richtig
mich noch erinnern kann
da war irgendwie sieben oder acht oder
so da kann ich echt sagen ich kann ich
das ding endlich drehen
26 hallo na gut ich war nicht da kann
ich dann wirklich sagen dass ich mich da
nicht gefragt habe wo kommen eigentlich
die geschenke her wenn meine mutter
gefragt mama hat mir geschenke vom vom
christkind kommen die eu nicht so wie
christian jethon 100 sondern ja das ist
der der geist der weihnacht und bleib
ich so ok schauen wir noch mal kurz hier
das ist irgendwie doch alles ein
bisschen komisch
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
ok und dann habe ich halt die ganze zeit
überlegt hinweisen das christkind wie
kommt der 1
dann habe ich als richtig überlegt so
meine eltern gefragt was soll da kommt
dann durch den schornstein wenn ihre
kirche seit wir den nicht jeder kommt er
nicht und plant was an ihm alles erzählt
und irgendwann war es dann nicht zu weit
ich dann mal war das doch nicht ans
gewinnen
da hat
hey das ist doch nicht mehr ins kind
altersgerecht komisch egal ob ich
einfach den der mine skin halt so ich
hab nämlich sonst einen tollen gürtel
und den hat der typ da nicht der nähe
hinnehmen dingsbums das ist echt komisch
sein eigenes kind man muss weil ich dann
ganz heimlich ach so ich dachte du passt
dass bei der papa mir dich okay
und dann war es bei mir ein gesundes mit
wie alt war ich zwölf war das schon
früher ich weiß es gerade gar nicht
jedenfalls habe ich dann wirklich
realisiert soll denn die geschenke
eigentlich hier ankommen wenn wir in der
kirche sind als abt einstigen
zwischenrufen geht sage ich mal obwohl
wir gar kein gar keinen kamin so richtig
hatten damals
da war ich dann schon so ein bisschen
hinterfragend sag ich mal ein wenig
kritisch gestimmt ist der der das geht
von hinten ist eigentlich egal wer da
muss ich mich dann immer von hinten
gucken
obwohl köppel ohren kriegen und dann hab
ich dann habe ich mir halt gedacht so
eigentlich geht das er nicht vielleicht
sind das ja doch die älteren die das
gemacht haben und dann meinte meine
mutter aber irgendwann damals als ich 14
war ja das ist die oma die tat macht und
blau und die haben halt ganz süß dass
meine eltern die ganze zeit versucht
haben nichts mit dem glauben zu lassen
und ich glaube ich wird das auch so mit
meinen kindern machen was ich zähle auch
dass drei oder vier pixel sind 1234
heute dritte von links und dann aber 1 2
3 4 5
es ist komisch 1 so geht so es cool
super 1 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
okay finde ich auf jeden fall ganz cool
7 hier hoch so also das jetzt erstmal
zum thema ich heiße letzte mal doof wenn
man wenn man so was dort wo man sie die
ganze zeit gucken muss da kann man
natürlich nicht jetzt durchgängig reden
das heißt wenn ihr euch besteht ja ich
weiß ich bin nicht so die multitasking
person schlechthin
ich bin nicht so die multitasking mehr
so schlecht wir wollen das jetzt hier
servette 3 2 zur seite 112 seite 11
passt das denn jetzt wo passt wenigstens
die sonne geht unter den acht minuten
aufgenommen
gar keine zeit mehr für alles so ok du
musst das und so das ist mein bart ja
wunderschöner bad nehmen sein dass hier
brot machen ist da wenn ich mein haus
ist immer richtig einfach weil der mann
mein mann mein villagers gegenteil von
dem ist allerdings ist schon geil und
jetzt guckt euch dieses panorama hier an
das ist alles so richtig schön farben
farbenfroh seite nicht farbe ndf abend
ist ja komischer ausdruck dass mein bart
bekomme ich momentan sap 0 wir brauchen
jetzt den kopf der muss doch so ein
bisschen überstehen sage ich nur den
kopf ist aber komischerweise genau so
brettin kompletter barth hatten der fünf
hätten kopf von fetten kopf er übrigens
haben mich immer noch leute
angeschrieben und meinten so ja wo
bleibt lost und so tut mir leid leute
aber ich habe ja gesagt dass lost & drop
kraft nicht in der zeit kommen wo hier
christus kraft gerade läuft weil ganz
easy christmas kraft finde ich hat etwas
mit weihnachten zu tun und da sollte man
nicht andere sachen hochladen sage ich
mal wenn ihr da ungefähr ein bisschen
versteht was ich meine mama 1 2 ach das
ist ein bart jetzt traf ich das erst des
in cannes an den so schlecht darstellen
ist aber nachher dann komisch aus
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
dies mein gesicht ja auch sieben große
nicht egal ich mache den bart mal ein
bisschen anders versteht da warte ich
zeige dass man warte das gesicht muss
auf jeden fall
ich mache hat man so also das ist für
mich jetzt hautfarbe einfach mal ne so 2
ich mach das mal elf mal komplett 3 4 5
6 7
so das ist sag ich mal so das gesicht 46
und damit man nachher wie die augen
drauf ich bei den sketchen wie gesagt
ich bei den ski nur von ford so kommen
dann die augen handy kommt von oben 1234
dann kommen da die augen die zwei zur
seite dann vier es heisst 1 2340 schon
ein bisschen hier muss allerdings jeder
bad natürlich eine ganz körperbehaarung
dieser affe natürlich noch mal kurz
gucken wenn man wie viel zur seite 123
zur seite und fünf unter 123 13 hier
kommen die augen hin mein gott diese
weise total komisch aus wenn die das
hier so sagen dann muss das natürlich
stimmen sie echt komisch aus so können
die augen immer noch komisch naja ich
hab jetzt nicht gedacht dass wir
theoretisch und mund hin machen könnten
und dann könnten wir eigentlich hier so
eine art party machen so irgendwie
visser dem bad in cannes
das hält man von hier geht ja noch
sollte man kann erkennen dass es dann
irgendwie so ein weihnachtsmann
darstellen soll sage ich mal
aber naja also dann man braucht schon
fantasie um das zu erkennen sagt ich
mache ja ich sag ja selber immer dass
ich nicht der beste
typ 4 bin ja okay kommt meine man kann
erkennen ja es geht schon klar läuft und
da unten geht an den boards zu werke
dann versuchen wir jetzt uns mal in den
arm schon von den erben schon und
erstmal die rückseite
ok und ist einfach das alles schwarz
schwarztee paar vivi weltmeister hat
denn ich mache das einfach zwei so hier
schwarz-rot oder schwarz-grün kaputt
macht das rot und alles wieder eine
reihe schwarz rot und übrigens ihr könnt
ihr immer kräftig in die kommentare
schreiben
was denn quatschen soll der folge
christkind das ist jetzt komisches thema
gewesen ist gebe ich ganz offen zu aber
irgendwie sowas wie dein lieblings
weihnachtsgeschenk was du je bekommen
rast oder irgendwie sowas halt solche
themen habe ich auch schon alle gesehen
und dafür wollte ich mich einfach mal
bedanken ich möchte natürlich jetzt
nicht alles nur themen aus der ersten
folge nehmen sage ich mal
weil das dann natürlich sogar von wegen
ja du guckst die anderen ja ja bla bla
ich nehme da schon themen und auch eure
geschichten sage ich mal mit dem neben
gewinnspielen teilnehmen könnt nämlich
schon aus jeder folge ist desto mehr
kommentare hier schreibt unter welchen
folgen auch immer habt ihr quasi den
vorteil dass ihr auch er drankommt sage
ich mal so viel dass man einfach hier
eben mit road zu ende
aber nur weil ich verstehe nicht warum
man meinen weihnachtsmann typ jetzt
hinten auch noch im bad hat guckt euch
das an der hinten auch noch so dass es
vielleicht noch hinten so rumliegt alles
kann das kann natürlich sein und ja ihr
bekommt die welt nachher zum download
also haben wir echt immens wieder
gefragt die sache die ich werde die welt
nicht ganz normal bei media feier
hochladen so wie ich das sonst mit welt
mache sondern bei meiner website
control.de also dies noch nicht fertig
da braucht jetzt noch gar nicht drauf
gehen weil die führt zurzeit nur zu
meinem kanal aber die ist bald fertig
und zwar mehr viele leute gesagt hey du
der dena wertet eine website und katja
oberberg und der nato website und deren
bla bla bla mache dir doch mal auch ein
und ein nach der ein gebäude das er
nicht weil ich lade videos bei youtube
hoch und bin sonst eigentlich relativ
inaktiv bei sozialen netzwerken sage ich
mal
was jetzt zu youtube angeht kann ich
kann mir nicht von der seite sehen das
ist doof na gut okay ich bau dir einfach
so wie ich denke jedenfalls was ich tue
so als wenn das eine mütze werde auf
dieses rote altert wird eine richtig
lange folgende goldrichtig chrysler
na gut okay ihr seid es mir wert macht
das hier alles nur für euch naja
jedenfalls wird wollte ich noch mal
sagen dingsbums hier wollte ich noch mal
oder willst ach ja bei meiner website
da habe ich mir gedacht ja ich werde
nicht so aktiv eigentlich bräuchte die
webseiten der meinten ganz viele leute
zu mir du kannst dann das machen und du
kannst du deine downloads hochladen und
du kannst du auch news schreiben zu
spielen das wollte es besser machen und
blabla der kommentar ist ganz cool da
hat mich genau in dem moment wo ich mir
das überlegt habe sogar eine person
angeschrieben die wir das machen wollte
die mir dabei jetzt geholfen hat das
alles so umzusetzen wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe mir sehr sehr dankbar
darüber über diese person die heißt
dominik und ja die website wird bald
halt online gehen als ich weiß nicht ob
ich das noch in diesem jahr schaffen
werde weil wir müssen natürlich erst mit
ihren videos dann dort verlinken etc pp
das ist auf jeden fall eine menge aber
nicht so wie ihr denkt ja wir machen da
mal eben schnell die website so schnell
ist geht das jetzt wieder nicht vor
allem weil die auch gerade mal zwei
wochen oder drei wochen in entwicklung
ist
ich habe jetzt einfach schon beim neuen
kanal design so ich sag mal einen
eingebunden sind nämlich um halt
hingeschrieben pubcon crafter die bald
verfügbar also bald könnt ihr ja echt
dann immer da die live stream schauen da
wäre ich auch öfters livestreams machen
weil ich dann halt auf meiner website
dort verlinkt werden blabla und dann
einfach auf der website vorbeischauen da
ist dies übrigens glaube ich werbefrei
als ich denke ich werde die werbefrei
machen weil mich einfach das aufregt
wenn also fette werden am rand ist bei
youtube kann ich nicht beeinflussen kann
ich musste ja doch noch irgendwie mal
hier das alles finanzieren
die ganzen intensivieren die ich bau dir
ins programm etc da muss das ein
bisschen
finanzieren es ist schon schön aus okay
es geht
und jetzt ein bisschen dünn na ja gut
das ist jetzt der bad sage ich mal so
von hinten jetzt auch nicht so
wunderschön aber kann man lassen
so kommen wir schon muss jetzt mal
gleich zeit so ist das schnell die
ärmsten die emsstadt mache ich so kann
ich doch die arme sind genau gleich fast
erwartet man legt eine hand an
ok hier muss hautfarbe hin so ich noch
mal so ganz ganz fette arme vista oder
es ist schwerer zu fett
ich mach das mal einfach so kann ich
dich macht ihm einfach drei dann sieht
das so aus als ob das ein bisschen noch
nach vorne zeigt sage ich möchte
überhaupt richtig haha ich mach's falsch
so muss ich die machen nicht da oben 1
darunter so so
gut und da muss jetzt weiß darüber blog
blog blog blog blog blog und am 24
dezember kommt einerseits eine
extralange folge christmas kraft weil
dann bei mir klausurphase wieder vorbei
ist das geil ist ich schreibe alle
klausuren vor den ferien also vor den
winterferien das heißt in die
winterferien
ok ich muss noch eine facharbeit
schreiben ich schreibe in deutsch über
die eloquente eloquente entwicklung in
der deutschen artikulation theorien
sprache so hat mir das mein lehrer
aufgetragen als man darf ja selber ein
team aussuchen und ich habe ja
deutschland kurs und ich liebe einfach
deutsch also innerhalb klausur über das
über goethe haben wir eine klausur
geschrieben und jetzt in zwei plus vier
grad schon wieder ein bisschen der will
nicht schaffe ich noch länger aufnehmen
da und dort schreibe ich nun eine eine
facharbeit und die wird dann sehr lange
und da muss ich dann noch in spezielle
universitäten fahren und mit dingen zu
holen und so weit komme ich nach dem
noch mal zu einem baum hier könnte man
theoretisch die eine hand hier so zum
daumen umformen sage ich mal
die das nicht in doha und mit einander
halt prospekte huep die bücher holen
prospekte genau prospekte so ja mein
gott oh mein gott
gut möglich ist dinge ist dass mein
körper okay gut das foto lade ich jetzt
erstmal bei facebook hoch alles oder
alle die das hier gerade sehen die haben
das foto dann auch schon bei facebook
gesehen
killer okay gut das was mit frist folge
zwei jedenfalls ach so was ich sagen
wollte 24 dezember kommt nicht sehr
lange folge warum weil ich schon alle
klausuren geschrieben hat und dann
einfach zeit habe eine extra lange folge
zu machen dass ich denke eine stunde
christmas kraft wo ich dann einfach ein
bisschen quatsch ich danke sagen für das
kommende jahr und so weiter etc das bin
ich etwas das man ihm so kommt jetzt
auch noch vernünftiges foto hier machen
rose sagt assistent schild wurde
ich würde auch das sind schweizer
katastrophe ja von minecraft na gut ich
habe schon alter 22 minuten
orga team ein internet lässt sich freuen
wenn ich das hochladen wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal freunde auch so
bewerten nicht vergessen e10 abschaffen
wir 500 zu diesem geilen typen hier na
ja lt p gt der beschreibung facebook und
so weiter wie es beim nächsten mal
tschüss